hey folks this is tim ferriss and i'm
answering a question a request
from alice d this is daily practices
strategies to fight depression she's
asking this in part
i think because i have spoken about and
written about
my history with depression so up until
about eight years ago
had i would say two major depressive
episodes per year at a minimum
that were extended so at least several
weeks
and the short answer to what happened
eight years ago is i began looking very
closely at
psychedelic medicine and psychedelic
science not going to get into that in
this particular episode though that is
a subject for its own dedicated episode
and there's a lot of writing and also
many interviews in my podcast related to
that at tim dot blog
podcast if you want to explore that
topic further
you can start with the michael pollan
episodes where we basically explore all
the content of his book how to change
your mind
in two hours that's an important piece
of certainly my personal journey
with depression but there are other
tools that have proven to be
incredibly valuable here are a few of
them i'm going to look at this list
because i want to make sure i get each
of these the first is meditation
meditating 10 to 20 minutes each morning
it is just an incredibly
helpful tool for becoming better able
to observe your own thoughts and
feelings and not fully identify with
them
depression for me is sort of a fixation
on
the past or a fixation on permanence
whereas anxiety is a fixation being
trapped in the future in a sense
when you make things personal and
permanent usually that is when you
basically become
a thought pattern or a loop and
meditation helps you
to develop an observer capability so you
can look at them and scrutinize them and
turn them around
and really better understand that they
are
passing phenomena and that everything is
impermanent
a few different options for that
transcendental meditation i do use
and have found very helpful i use the
waking up app with sam harris
i recommend doing the introductory
course it's very very good and i think
it's 10 minutes per morning for
something like 30
mornings and that consistency will also
provide you with skills that are layered
in
and there's a progression so i highly
recommend the waking up app and that is
a
fantastic place to start cold exposure
is another option that i use so i happen
to have
a small pool but i've used cold showers
you can even create a cold plunge
with a chest freezer and there are
instructions online for how to do this
safely do not electrocute yourself
but i will usually use cold plunge in
the mornings
at least once and then in the evenings
oftentimes again
with some type of contrast therapy going
hot cold in the winters
when things are overcast which has a
tremendous effect on me
i use a phillips go light this is a blue
light a portable blue light that you can
put on your desktop
there is research to support this i care
more about the actual outcomes
it does help tremendously as a form of
medication
after that caffeine all right what role
does caffeine
play what are its limitations i find
that keeping my caffeine intake to
before noon
or before 1 pm is incredibly important
it's important because
if i have it later than that it starts
to compromise my sleep
and if i compromise my sleep everything
falls apart
to me sleep quality
is directly correlated to mental health
so if i'm sacrificing sleep quality
the likelihood of a depressive episode
or experiencing depression goes up
dramatically and this is particularly
true over a course of multiple
consecutive days
and many of you will have had the
experience you have caffeine too late
you can't sleep you sleep a little later
or you just wake up early nonetheless
and you end up having more caffeine to
get through the day and then yet
more caffeine again to get through the
third day and last but not least
i would say exercise critically
important the mind and the body are not
separate they're really one in the same
in a lot of respects there's a book
called spark that looks very closely
at the research to support this and how
exercise affects brain drive
neurotrophic factor and many other
things that contribute to
ultimately mental wellness so a few easy
options particularly
in times of pandemic kettlebell look at
getting a kettlebell
the footprint on your floor will be
about that big
so it takes up the same amount of space
as a door weight
a large doorway but you can use it for
almost any type of exercise
pavel tatzulin and strong first have a
lot of fantastic programs very simple
programs
and i've also put out videos on
kettlebell swings so you can look
at my instructions for the two-handed
kettlebell swing
last two recommendations related to
exercise would be
number one consider doing some form of
yoga or acro yoga
if you have another person you can do
acro yoga with it injects both
play and exercise slash training into
your life
it's an incredible combination check out
jason niemer nemer n-e-m-e-r
for more on acroyoga that has saved me
and my girlfriend
throughout the last year of covid and
quarantine and so on
and second is simple walking walking
long walks
there is almost no problem you cannot
walk your way
out of so i will routinely walk one to
two to three hours a day listening to
podcasts that are conversations
also because i think that attenuates any
feeling of loneliness or isolation
and if you want to make it harder you
can check out a company called goruck
they sell backpacks that are
specifically designed to carry weight
so if you want to try something that's a
little easier on the joints than running
but can still give you a wonderful
workout
consider wrecking and one such company
is goruck
and with all of that i wish you well you
are not alone
sometimes it's better to snuggle with
your demons
snuggle instead of struggle with them
and
it's important to forgive yourself for
something that is very normal and in
fact
extremely common which is the experience
of sadness loneliness
and depression that is part of being
human especially during a pandemic
so that's very important to remind
yourself of
and i hope these tools help you as much
as they've helped me
you